it's always been pretty gnarly my social
anxiety
paris jackson is opening up about her
struggles with mental health
i don't really expect anyone else to
understand on wednesday paris appeared
on a new episode of red table talk
chatting with willow smith on how fame
triggered her social anxiety
and ptsd i experience audio
hallucinations sometimes with camera
clicks
and severe paranoia and have been going
to therapy for a lot of things but that
included and i've like started
like you hear okay i'll hear like a
trash bag rustling and i like flinch and
panic
is that from the paparazzi yeah i think
it's just like
just standard ptsd the singer also goes
on to say that she's had
nightmares and that she doesn't like to
go out during the day
but she's working on healing that aspect
of her life
[Applause] [Music]
willow and paris also bond over some of
the downsides of being in the spotlight
revealing they're very protective of who
they let into their inner circle i'm
very paranoid about like information
right
like if i'm telling you everyone that
walks into my house signs into you yeah
that's gnarly it's gnarly like even
being like oh like delete that text
because i don't want people to like oh
yeah it does a lot to your nervous
system
because you're constantly in fight or
flight exactly fight flight freeze
collapse you're constantly like walking
on eggshells constantly looking over
your shoulder
like you have to sit up straight and act
right because if you don't it not only
reflects on your reputation
your family's reputation paris opened up
about her experience contemplating
suicide
admitting there were times she was upset
it didn't work but now she says
things have gotten better i think it's
everything man i think a lot of it was
just not knowing who i was uh being a
young girl
going through puberty and probably a lot
of just
my situation and a lot of pressure it
was really hard and like totally
tell me to kill myself every day and i
was depressed
but now paris has channeled that
challenging period in her life
into her music releasing her debut album
wilted
back in november you had said that music
saved your life
oh for sure it makes me feel less alone
and it makes me feel
heard there were some dark dark times
where
i did feel like music was all i had i
feel like it's still probably there
somewhere
in the back of my head but the louder
thing that competes is that i feel like
my dad would be proud
in 2018 paris opened up to e.t about her
late father
michael jackson and how she will
continue to remember the king of pop
and his legacy family to me is a feeling
and again
with expectations we honor him in our
own way and
i don't really expect anyone else to
understand besides this dude right here
and so
i'm just happy to be with him like it's
just it's love
and great feeling